all right joining us now the author of
now a bestseller get Trump and it deals
with every legal issue the president's
facing Harvard Law Professor Alan
dershowitz is with us and the author of
The soon to be released trial of the
Century Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett I understand Professor
dershowitz that you said at the judge
issues a gag order you will file an
amicus brief and argue that we citizens
are being denied the the ability to hear
the defendant to not only a defendant
Professor but he's also a presidential
candidate and they did this in the Roger
Stone case I think they might have done
it in the manafort case I don't fully
remember my question to you is how do
you how does a judge get to take away
the right of an American to speak out on
their own behalf on a on a very public
case like this
tragically judges have done that they've
done it recently I was glad to see Joe
be optimistic that they're not going to
do it in this case but if they did do it
in this case I would immediately put
together some of the great first
amendment lawyers in America as Amicus
because we would be the victims there
are two First Amendment rights the right
of the speaker but the right of the
listener according to Justice Thurgood
Marshall is just as important but I hope
that won't happen because that would
really mean a a body blow to the First
Amendment and today you couldn't even
count on the American civil liberties
Union to defend the First Amendment on
behalf of Donald Trump because they
would lose all of their funding you know
the only disagreement I have with Joe is
a great lawyer I think he's too much of
an optimist I cannot imagine an elected
judge in the borough of Manhattan
throwing out this case and having to go
to his family and say I'm the lawyer who
freed Donald called Trump or his friends
or his business associates all he has to
do is remember what happened to me when
I defended just defended Donald Trump on
the Senate lost all of my friends
clients business associates and no judge
is going to want to be quote dershowitz
so you're not going to have an
opportunity to get a fair assessment of
statute of limitations change of venue
this is a fixed case if it's tried in
Manhattan and in my professor hold on a
second you're a Harvard professor and
you're basically saying the rule of law
does not exist here you are basically
saying go ahead
it does not exist for Donald Trump in my
book get Trump I prove that the rule of
law has an exemption there is the rule
for everybody else and there's the rule
for Donald Trump his lawyers his
associates his family this from a man
who voted against Trump and intends to
vote him against him again Donald Trump
wrote to me today as he was getting on
the plane he said Alan getting ready to
leave in New York can't really believe
it these Maniacs want to destroy our
country so sad nothing on hunter or
Biden anyway your words are very
important save America P.S congrats on
the book doing very very well the thesis
of the book is the rule of law does not
apply to Donald Trump in the borough of
Manhattan there is no way he gets a fair
trial man and you go through Fulton
County and you go through the special
counsel and you make the case on on
every one of the charges that are being
brought up against him let me bring in
Greg let's talk about a change of venue
let's talk about the statute of
limitations prosecutorial abuse
selective prosecution you know Greg I
look at all these issues to me it's all
slam dunk uh all of these things should
throw this case out immediately but yet
that doesn't appear to be happening
yeah but you've identified all the
things that lead me to now believe that
we don't have a justice system anymore
we only have a legal system and it it
appears corrupted and Americans
recognize this they've lost faith in our
legal system and there's a reason why
Trump's polling numbers have suddenly
shot up his campaign coffers are now
filled with millions of dollars over the
last three days because Americans are
very smart people and they see what's
going on this is a persecution disguised
as a prosecution they recognize that
this is a feeble zombie case resurrected
from the dead and is purely politically
motivated a whopping 76 percent in the
latest CNN polls say this is politically
motivated and they're right it is but
there are other reasons that are deeply
troubling to Americans and why they
don't like this they see this as a
purely really personal matter a relic of
a case that happened a great many years
ago and yes the staff statute of
limitations long ago passed but most of
all you know they see this as the same
old tired act it's a replay of the
Russia hoax government officials egged
on by democrats going after a political
opponent with vengeance it was the
greatest mass delusion in American
political history and you would think
that the government has learned from
this but you've got a local prosecutor
who now wants to put on trial the
leading opponent of his Bragg's
political party and I think in the end
this is going to backfire tremendously
let me ask you a professor I want I want
to look at this novel legal theory that
they're using here never been used
before would they take a state
misdemeanor case where clearly the
statute of limitations are way over was
what two years uh Marriott to a federal
election law whose statute of
limitations I would argue are also have
passed uh yet they put this together
this has never happened before but
they're doing this to him now keep in
mind this is a prosecutor that in 52
percent of felony cases reduces those
felonies to misdemeanors this is the
only time he's taking a misdemeanor and
trying to raise it to the level of a
felony that's why I'd like to see brag
himself try this case
uh yeah one reason was completely
ludicrous on on its face and you know I
think it will face motions to dismiss
not just on the statute of limitations
but the argument that the law doesn't
support this kind of a charge and the
alleged facts don't support a crime so
you know I would like to see a honest
judge objective and neutral look at
these motions to dismiss seriously and
sincerely I slightly disagree with the
professor I do think that most judges do
not want to be and are fearful of being
overturned by a higher court and I hope
that gives this particular judge pause
when he considers the Motions to dismiss
same question
in that case in this case a judge would
rather be reversed on appeal than have
to come home and look his wife and
family in the eye and say I let Trump
out also the Appellate Court judges are
elected this is going to be a very hard
case in which to get Justice look the
statute of limitations issue is so clear
they could have indicted him anytime in
the last six years they say no he was
out of the state but when did they
indict him they indicted him when he was
out of the state in Florida what's the
difference the virtue of a statute of
limitations argument is that might be
appealable right away whereas these
other arguments about selective
prosecution about whether or not the
statute really covers this you have to
wait for a conviction to appeal though
so there's some virtue in making change
of venue statute of limitations
arguments that are appealable in terms
of the basic case there's no misdemeanor
here let me explain why there's no
misdemeanor so there was a payment made
the payment was made 8 to prevent
information from coming out to his wife
and family and business associates about
an alleged Affair and brag is saying
once he paid the money to keep
everything quiet he should have listed
it on his corporate form as hush money
pay to a former porn star never in the
history of the world has anybody ever
paid hush money and then put it on a
public forum it's always disguised never
in history is any disguised because
legally it's a non-disclosure agreement
you're not even allowed to talk about it
publicly
but remember the other aspect of it the
the falsifying of business records is
allegedly a fraud according to Brad well
who has he defrauded his own business so
this is utter nonsense and the predicate
crime of the misdemeanor uh expired five
years ago I just don't see how you get
there if you're Alvin I got to leave you
both here
all right questions don't discuss this
in this case don't expect it it's not
gonna happen maybe when it gets to the
Supreme Court but not in the borough of
Manhattan I love Manhattan I spend time
in Manhattan but I wouldn't agree with
you professor
he can't get a fair trial he they need
to have a change of venue and I don't
believe that motion will succeed and I
wish I was wrong uh thank you both Alan
dershowitz Greg Jarrett hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else